people have a lot of questions about the
economy they're wondering what's
happening right now particularly with
the coronavirus out there you have a lot
of economic data at your fingertips
because not only on the many businesses
that Berkshire owns but the businesses
you own pieces in what are you seeing
right now around the globe well it
affects various businesses on I would I
would say that I received commentary I
get some commentary monthly but from
from almost all of the companies and a
good many of them had some comment about
how it was affecting them and however it
was affecting them that at that time I'm
sure it's accentuated but they've been
affected by a were affected by
terrorists are affected by taxes they're
affected by the most thing is they're
affected my competitors in supply and
demand over time and I don't have the
faintest idea what our businesses will
be doing six months from now or twelve
months from now I do think that not only
our businesses but American business
generally we doing fabulously better
thirty years from now for 20 years now
and the the long term is very in my view
is very easy to predict in the general
way but an important way I don't think
there's any way to predict what the
stock market will do 10 minutes from now
10 days from now or 10 months from now
so I work on what I think I am able to
do and as desirable as it might be to
know what was going to happen 10 minutes
from now that's just not something I
don't ever be able to master so
fortunately I can come to a pretty firm
conclusion that 20 or 30 years from now
America business and probably all over
the world will be far better than it is
now what are the momentary implications
that you've seen from coronavirus what's
an example of a business well an example
for example we have maybe a thousand
Dairy Queen franchises in China here and
they're just treat only so they're
they're the old older type not with food
but a great number of them were closed
but the ones that were open we're doing
any business to speak of and and apples
I mean are much bigger holding is a buil
and 5.6 percent of Apple and
and the company came out and said that
it's affecting not only its stores but
all kinds of things supply chain and I
find that certain of our companies have
got supply chain arrangements that are
being affected by this that I didn't
even know had those like what well I got
one from Johns Manville the other day
for example you wouldn't normally think
of them as having a big supply chain but
Shaw carpenter you name it
I'll guarantee you that a very
significant percentage of our business
is one layer affected by but they're
being affected by a lot of other things
too and the real question is is why are
those businesses going to be in five or
ten years don't have ups and downs our
candy business is a wonderful business
but it loses money seven months out of
the year but then I think as Christmas
comes every year Nelson Mandela once
said the courage is not the absence of
fear but the triumph over it we're all
feeling that right now when thinking of
Mandela's words I think of the courage
and the resilience of the people of
South Africa 56 million brave souls who
have endured so much for so long and now
have to face down this pandemic while
also reconciling on a daily basis
injustice and inequality and communities
still ransacked by HIV and AIDS but they
keep going and in every country in every
continent we have seen such phenomenal
acts of courage from people who are on
the front lines of this fight against
coronavirus I tell you we all
appreciated health care workers but
never like now
they have done this often at
considerable risk to themselves because
when there are lives at stake their
first thoughts are not about themselves
but for others they truly are
the best of us and their compassion and
their true acts of service is a call to
action for all of us we need to ensure
that governments around the world step
up now and provide the healthcare
workers with the equipment with the
funds with the support they need and
tonight we stand as one world United in
our fight to rid the world of this
disease and to ensure that nothing like
this ever happens again and when and if
it does we will be ready
hey everyone had a thought in these
strange times we've been asked to
practice social distancing one of the
problems with that is is that we're
social animals and when you take people
away from social animals it makes us
feel lonely makes us feel disconnected
and so I think we have to put an extra
effort to find ways to remain close to
people so just like when we're walking
down a hallway in the office and we
stick our head into somebody's office
and say hey how was your weekend let us
pick up the phone let us have a FaceTime
call or a zoom call as often as possible
let us not rely on text remember we all
know that texting is already
disconnected and now that we have even
fewer opportunities to connect with each
other and we're isolated in our own
homes many of us alone when you want to
check in with someone please call please
get a videoconference because I know
that I would like it and I know that
other people would too there is a mono
spirit and there's a mono spirit that I
talked about that is in all of us that
just it permeates us and that Manas
spirit is a spirit of it's a spirit of
anchoring it's a spirit of gratitude
it's a spirit of a warrior sense that
we're going to get through this thing so
I do believe that and I try and tap into
Montes spirit every day when I'm just
giving my thanks
you know to the universe and a good Lord
above I just closed for Neil like where
did coronavirus come from it kind of
just seemed like it just you know popped
up out of nowhere and like you know we
just started hearing about it in China
and then suddenly everywhere and why do
people keep moving the people that are
infected around I mean now it's in North
Carolina like yeah it's it's it's it's
where they come from so so I'll go back
through it so how does it get around
airplanes we're all on airplanes that's
the fastest way a virus can move from
one continent to another infect somebody
the person goes 5,000 miles and an
airplane drops off and then sneezes on
somebody there so so our modern
civilization is the ideal mechanism for
the spread of diseases back when we were
nomadic or we had tribes diseases never
spread it would hardly be any diseases
uh-huh because the we that only really
happened once people started collecting
in cities once they sat but once they
sat yeah and then you alright so that's
a be the whole point of the Tree of Life
the reason why we have the biodiversity
we do is because life is opportunistic
and it will evolve by natural selection
and viruses and bacteria are doing this
all the time the people say I don't
believe in evolution I'd be okay that's
you know if sarcasm fighting them
engineering everything everything's
fighting even the virus yes I get that
even the virus so the virus said well
this isn't working I'm not so there's a
version of a virus by the way even the
corona virus has sub strands within it
they're tests that's how they know where
some of them come from and others don't
they were studying the coral virus in
the Pacific Northwest and they you can
track the the evolutionary changes in it
in one region of the country versus
another to help you track where
ultimately came from so it looks like
this one actually came
in and from the center of China what's
the name of the town Mahon Wuhan China
and that's okay meaning that's where it
first appeared and other other viruses
that were new like Legionnaires disease
these are viruses or bacteria that would
have no precedent infecting us mm-hmm
then they species jump and when they
species jump it's a brand new pathogen
in our in our civilization and that'll
just keep happening Oh fear not fear not
I know a lot is coming at us we are
hearing a lot there's all sorts of
predictions about what's happening and
how it's happening and why it's
happening and things are changing moment
by moment and I still say fear not fear
not because we know fear is an energy
that attracts the very thing that we
want to avoid fear not there are things
that we can do to protect ourselves
whether it's the washing of our hands or
the staying in the house or just
covering ourselves fear not fear is not
going to avoid you from getting this or
fear is not gonna keep it away from you
but what fear does is it creates
thoughts and energies and our minds that
lead us into a state of stress and
anxiety so I just want to talk about
some things that we can do to keep
ourselves calm to keep ourselves
peaceful so that no matter what happens
whether we face this health challenge or
not that we will be okay start your day
with some prayer affirmation centering
grounding so that what you hear in the
world doesn't create tension and stress
in your body start your day with
grounding and centering we don't have to
figure out why oh uh who's fault or
who's
doing what and I would also encourage
you to limit the intake of what's coming
in because there are some doom and gloom
predictions and yes we want to know
what's going on
listen locally listen nationally but
limit your intake don't sit and listen
to this all day long because it just
grows the energy of fear it's just an
anxiety in your body and listen to your
body have a conversation with your body
have a conversation with yourself so
that you remain calm
remember your affirmation now
affirmation is not going to keep you
from getting something that you would
get but let us remember that the fear
visit the flu visit sucks every year and
last year alone over 60,000 people died
from the flu okay so fear not this is
something else that's coming to us this
is something else that's pushing us to
be stronger this is something else
that's bringing us together fear not
that is your greatest enemy right now
and if you feel yourself stressed and
anxious and and and worried tap pray
okay call in some light energy call in
the white light of the divine mind of
the Creator call in the holy spirit call
in something greater than any sickness
or illness on the planet if you want
more advice wisdom guidance from other
successful entrepreneurs on how you can
navigate the coronavirus situation check
out the video right there next to me I
hope you find it valuable continue to
believe and I'll see you there I would
challenge law to do is to remember this
she taught to believe everything you
think